what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to be reacting to a
video titled
how to manipulate women and breaking the
touch barrier
this looks like a lot of fun
i guess hahaha yay yay
so fun okay before i start do not forget
to like comment and subscribe
especially subscribe guys i'm really
trying to grow this channel
really trying to make a career out of
this every single subscriber
helps me get to that goal so if just if
you like my content
hit that subscribe button i'd really
appreciate it
okay this is by oh yeah it's by alpha
male strategies
my favorite he this last video
wasn't terrible but
okay
what's up fellas so today we're here to
talk about how to manipulate women
all right guys so first off
before you know i go in and follow that
i want i really don't like his camera
angle
like it's like mostly tv or the mostly
um
ceiling i'm gonna give you a disclaimer
on this [ __ ] video
all right to manipulate anybody
all right male or female means that
you're
pretty much playing with somebody's
emotions all right
that's what the manipulation is you're
playing with somebody emotions so
anytime you're playing with somebody
emotions you run the risk of getting
your ass [ __ ] up all right you run the
risk of somebody hurting your ass
all right whenever y'all guys see uh
well sometimes some guy's just crazy but
a lot of times when y'all see guys
kill women and [ __ ] like that that's
because that guy has been manipulated
all right that woman has made him feel a
certain type of way
but her actions are not displaying it i
she has
gotten that man so emotional one day
she's all over them the next day she's
doing this that the next day she's all
over and next day she's doing this
so please believe god that when any time
and there's a reason why you mostly only
see
guys kill girls and not girls kill guys
because we as men have a [ __ ] heart
all right no that's not true it's
because
it's i learned this from a psychologist
it's because of the trait agreeableness
so if somebody is more agreeable
um they're like i think the best way to
explain it like
if someone's agreeable just basically
means they're like more go with the flow
of kind friendly care and compassion
it's someone that's disagreeable isn't
it disagreeable is good for like
leadership because you really don't care
what people think and you like
you tell people exactly what you want
disagree or agreeable people beat around
the bush more
so people that are on the extremely high
end of the disagreeable scale those are
the people that end up in prison
men are standard deviation higher in
disagreeableness than women
that's how they don't have a heart what
the [ __ ]
all right that's why y'all see that
that's why y'all don't see women out
here killing me because
most men do not believe in playing with
women's emotions
that's not true most pet men don't have
the opportunity to
but most guys that have the opportunity
to do
it's like wow you see high value men
like cheat
most of us have [ __ ] morals all right
most women are
unmora they don't give a [ __ ] about your
feelings all right that's the bottom
[ __ ] line that's why you see them all
the time getting their [ __ ] head
blown off and [ __ ] like this on news and
[ __ ]
not saying that's right but what i'm
saying is this is what happens when you
play with
people in motions now i had a patron guy
actually pay me for this video so i'm
gonna make the [ __ ] video but i'm
putting that disclaimer
out there right now that you have to be
careful when you're doing [ __ ] like this
is because you're playing with people's
emotions and then when you get to
playing people in motion they're not
thinking straight
all right and they will [ __ ] they've
run the risk of hurting you i'm just
letting you know
so and for all you women out there that
you know play around and this that
knowledge you play around with guys
emotions and
[ __ ] like this please understand this is
how you get your [ __ ] head boss
it's interesting to see the
repercussions of women be
being basically man-haters in society
because this is the repercussion of that
like very obviously all right
manipulating playing with somebody's
emotions all right
so the first thing guys that before i
tell you anything else for them
you need to know that this only works if
the woman cares about you
right off the bat all right if a woman
don't even like your ass good luck
manipulating somebody who don't even
like your ass all right it don't work
that way
so first the woman has to care about you
now what did i say about
how you make a woman care about you well
guys with anybody
with your friends or anybody outside of
your mama your mama gonna care about you
regardless of what you do but
outside of your [ __ ] you know outside
of your mom and your and your brothers
and sisters as well the case may be
anybody friends employees can nobody
care about you or love you without them
respecting you
so first thing you need to know is a
woman can't care about you
unless she respects you all right so
before you go
trying to learn some manipulation
strategy this that other you need to be
a strong masculine man to what she
[ __ ] respects you and submits to you
all right so in other words if your
woman called you a [ __ ] [ __ ] last night
she don't love you she don't respect you
all right women when they respect you
they ain't gonna call you a [ __ ] made
[ __ ] or [ __ ] boy or all this another
[ __ ]
or you know a whole ass [ __ ] you know
when a woman is saying these type of
terms to you or called you a [ __ ] or
whatever the case may be
she don't respect you so good luck
manipulating a woman
that called you a whole ass [ __ ] all
right
do people do that in relationships
that's the bottom [ __ ] line guys why
would you be with someone that that's
how you talk to them
or why would you want to be with someone
that talks to you like that if you want
a woman to care about you
first she has to respect you so if you
hearing that you need to
kill that first all right so she needs
to be broken up with
and may come back submit that's how you
make a woman submit i've told you guys
over and over
you break up with her and then when she
comes back you ask her
how are you willing to make this up to
me all right so that's how that goes
guys
all right she has to be in a submissive
state to care about you
all right so
so what that's first thing
guys let's just break up with girls to
make them submit
all right now let's talk about how
women manipulate us all right okay well
let me tell you guys how women
manipulate you
they be all touchy philly all lipping
you all up in your arms
and you guys will see this now all right
you now that i'm saying this
watch and pay attention to it should be
all touchy-feely with you on the couch
just that other and then she'll just
pull back
all right just pull back guys that's
manipulation
all right i know you know a lot of
dating coaches might say well you know
women are you know they like to run away
like cats this that another dog
women are natural manipulators it comes
natural to them all right okay i'm
curious what he means by that because
obviously you can't be touchy feely all
the time you got
stuff to do so it ain't nothing for a
woman to go put a
short miniskirt on without booze all
hanging out
with the sole purpose of manipulating
you
that's the whole purpose it comes
natural to them all right
so what i teach you guys is you know
first we manipulate two we do hypergamy
we we
listen they playing on our testosterone
we play on a hypergamy that's the way it
goes guys both of those are not
well this hypergamy let me know in the
comments all right women don't [ __ ]
about
you know crying about us having
testosterone always wanting sex
well i'm teaching you guys don't [ __ ]
and complain about them having hypergamy
so we play on them
uh they have permanent programming with
our manipulation all right
but that's for another case i'm talking
about with a woman that you're dating
all right so a woman she gets touchy
philly
she pulls back she gives you a little
affection she pulls back
she suck your dick a little bit she
pulls back all right this gets you
emotional because you're never quite
sure where you stand with a woman
do you guys get that that's how you
that's how a person gets you emotional
when one minute you could swear she
loved you
in the next minute you don't know how
the [ __ ] she feel about you
that's how you get somebody emotional
all right if you want somebody not to be
emotional just let them know where they
stand with you tell them they tell them
you love them all the time
buying flowers every day that's listen
if you don't want somebody to
be emotional a really careful okay this
is the caveat
women don't like a man that they can
just like walk all over
because you don't feel like you actually
know him if a guy's just like kissing
your ass all the time
like there's a difference between like
kind gestures
and like guys that are afraid to hurt
your feelings or like tell you the truth
just let them know where you stand 24 7.
i tell you what you do text a good
morning baby i love you
good afternoon baby i love you good
night baby i love you and i thought
about you all day do that [ __ ]
all right get a person emotional and
[ __ ] like this here
they have to constantly wonder where
they stand with you now
if you're treating them like [ __ ] all
the time well they know what you stay
staying with you they know they
[ __ ] to you all right so you got to give
them a little love
that's how it goes women give you a
little facial kiss
suck your dick roger real good and then
the next minute they pull back a little
bit and they don't want to be near you
all this is natural female manipulation
that comes
natural to them they don't even have to
think about it give you a little love
and pull back so that's the same way you
manipulate them
all right but women are not curious
if my boyfriend was nearby i'm curious
if he thinks i do that
because i haven't done that definitely
not intentionally
but he's saying it happens naturally
but i don't really see that like
physical like us that's
i could be wrong though you know what i
mean like i've never thought about that
listen guys sexual innuendo that works
for us because we men
will physical with a woman you got to
get her mind
all right you're never going to get a
woman with physical you get her [ __ ]
mind
now i got a video on you on patreon a
few
uh videos back called uh
how to keep uh the conversation from
lose sexual energy
it's a few videos back guys y'all guys
go check it out y'all guys will know how
to talk to women and keep the sexual
energy
but basically guys you need to learn how
to conversate with women in a sexual
tone all right
that's how you get women emotional all
right
you got to make her have a certain type
of feeling when she's with you
and then you like a drug you pull it
back all right
that's how it goes so when she's with
you you know you you got this sexual
energy
she's submissive to you she's just crazy
about you
then you pull it back all right like a
drug you get them addicted to the drug
and then you take it away from them did
the same thing women do to you they be
all up in you boobs all on your chest
you feel
good man i got my girl i got my bill
this is great
and the next thing you know she's taking
your arm and she she needs a little
space
natural manipulators guys natural has
come natural to them
all right natural manipulators one
minute you know exactly where you're
staying with her the neck
that sounds like a lot of the women i've
seen on like kevin samuels show and like
the more like
masculine a bit crazy
women but
i don't really see that and the people i
know and like even my parents like
watching like
my parents have been married for almost
30 years i don't really see that
next minute you like and i know everyone
in the comments is going to be like
you can't use personal examples but
that's what all this is based on for him
unless he states like a study or
something
did i say something wrong you ain't
saying nothing wrong just natural
manipulators
all right so with women guys when they
with you you have to give them this
certain type of feel
and then you pull it back so this is the
basis of mixed signals guys
if you want to get if you want to
manipulate somebody you want to play
with somebody emotions
you're basically sending them mixed
signals all right you saying all the
right things you got her feeling that
tingle
don't none of this means [ __ ] without
her feeling submissive to you by the way
it don't mean [ __ ] listen yo guys if she
don't respect you
don't none of this means [ __ ] now i'm
gonna tell you guys why
does this work in the long term though
like a long-term healthy relationship
would that work it seems like a long
long game you'd have to like play women
care about guys who make them feel
submissive
guys it puts them in a natural feminist
state all right
a woman wants to be feminine when she's
around a man that makes her feel
submissive
that puts her in a natural feminine
state all right that's how a woman likes
to feel
all right and i'm gonna tell you
something that's what it goes to guys
women like to feel safe
when a man has to strength to make her
submit
by letting her know it's gonna be
consequences by the way all right to
your actions
when a man has the balls and a strength
to make her submit
she know this is a man that can stand up
for herself see guys
when a woman can't submit to you she
never feels
safe with you all right because you
can't even stand up to her
so you gonna stand up to me all right if
i was to come up and smack your ass
your girl on the ass she already know
you ain't gonna do [ __ ]
all right you can't even stand up to her
what the hell it's interesting because
i'm thinking about this because the most
successful marriage i know is obviously
my parents
and it's interesting because
i would say that my parents like
compromise on things so it's not like
one would like
what he says goes a hundred percent of
the way i'm
i can't even say my dad's like a beta
male because he owns
a software company like beta males can't
leave
hell makeup think you're gonna stand up
to a six five two hundred and thirty
pound guy
she don't need to guns all right that's
the thing guys a woman has to know
my man has a [ __ ] backbone he can
stand up to me i know he can stand up he
gonna stand up to any guy on the street
that's the way if guys listen women want
to be
feel feminine and safe all right that's
what the alpha male provides them a
feeling of safety
all right on top of that he knows all
the right things to say he keeps he
stays in his masculine frame
he keeps that sexual energy when it's
with his girl gives her that tingle
all right so for all you guys to think
you're just gonna
learn a couple of things and manipulate
if she don't give a [ __ ] about you
then what you manipulating she gotta
care about you first
all right you gotta give us something to
miss to manipulate
if she don't give a [ __ ] if you never
come back how are you going to
manipulate her
so it steps to this manipulation guys
first you need to get a woman completely
submissive to you
all right that's the number one thing
you need to know first foremost
she has to be completely submissive to
you by knowing that it's actions behind
what she do
that is going to be some consequences if
she ain't doing exactly what you want
her to do
that she need to follow your program to
a [ __ ] t to stay around
which is what she wants by the way that
makes her feel feminine
and safe because she knows you're a type
of guy that stands up for yourself
all right so ain't no skipping steps in
this [ __ ] guys
submissive right sexual energy
get uh intoxicated with you get her
addicted to you
and then you pull it back and then you
give her a little bit then you pull it
back and you get
now guys this right here you [ __ ]
with people emotions like i tell you
guys use this [ __ ]
you know the way you want to you know do
what you want to [ __ ] do
i'm just letting you know that if you
run the risk of doing this you playing
with people emotions
you running risk getting your head balls
i'm just letting you [ __ ] know guys
it's the god of the truth now the one
thing with this is
most women don't want to do nothing to
put themselves in jail or trouble or
stuff like this right here whatever the
case may be even if they care about you
so they'll cry to their friends a couple
of days
or whatever the case may be and then
move on but you know
with women they do [ __ ] like this and
you do it with the wrong guy
and then there you go all right so now
i want to talk about the touch bar i had
a guy a patron supporter hit me up
talking about the touch barrier
now guys the touch barrier is nothing
more than a
let me find out if you like me now i
told you guys this
you know a couple of times before so i'm
gonna say it again
women are not stupid all right women are
not stupid
women know what you're trying to touch
them for
they know you're trying to get a gauge
on a [ __ ] interest
which shows them you have no [ __ ]
confidence
like but i'm gonna tell you guys like
this here right here guys do what the
[ __ ] you want to do you can go up
touching grab a booze whatever the hell
you want to do
do whatever the hell you want to do i'm
just letting you know it lowers her
interest a little bit because
you're showing a little lack of
confidence women are not [ __ ] stupid
all right when you do these good morning
texts and [ __ ] like that
women know that's a check-in test that's
to see if she still likes you
all right that's what that was you any
text because you you really want to tell
a good morning you text to make sure she
takes you
back because she was wondering did she
still like you today
all right that's the same thing he
touched barry like i tell you guys
let the woman initiate contact on the
[ __ ] date
other than you if she come back to your
house okay now you finna get ready to
make a move
now you can do something but if you're
at a [ __ ] restaurant that's nothing
more
than let me check to see where i stand
let me check to see if you even like me
that's all that is
and the thing with you guys y'all don't
understand is women [ __ ] know that
you know i tell you guys this oh no
women know all these
i'm unsure of myself let me make sure
you even like me
all right that's one of them the touch
barrier another one is
uh asking a woman is she having a good
time on a date all these are you trying
to find out where you
stand never do no [ __ ] like that guys
you always want to carry yourself
as a confident man i got this in the
[ __ ] bag laid back
none of that i need to check to see
where i stand [ __ ] it's a
attraction killer i've told you guys
this before so i'll tell you guys this
again
when i was had when i was struggling
with the women i had a high attraction
for this is what i would do
all right and i would always wonder why
they would slowly lose attraction
the girls who i saw at sevens and eights
i never did none of that [ __ ] with i was
always kick back
and they always was all over me i only
did the
touch barrier with girls i had a super
high attraction for
and sure enough most times i would kill
attraction i will [ __ ] them sometimes
but you guys know what i mean when you
gotta when you [ __ ] with a 9 or a 10
you want to keep her in your rotation so
just because you [ __ ] it one time you
want to keep [ __ ] them
get what i'm saying so yes if you do
this [ __ ]
and lower some girls interesting [ __ ]
like this you might still [ __ ] them
but you want to keep [ __ ] them all
right that's the thing i'm trying to
teach you
a true gentleman guys i'm trying to
teach you guys how to keep a woman
interested
i don't teach um what they call that
[ __ ] um
a pump and dump i don't teach that i
teach rotations
i don't teach pump and dumb all right i
teach rotations
all right even uh masculine [ __ ] i
put them in the friend zone
i don't even unless they just getting
too uncooperative
or they ain't falling to my program even
in the friend zone that's when i dump
other than that even those masculine
[ __ ] i just take all my non-sexual
attention away
and put theirs in the [ __ ] friend
zone guys i don't even [ __ ] dump
their ass
i believe in rotation all right when you
get emotional and you want to just dump
girls to the side just that off i'ma
tell you this [ __ ] now
a drought has your name on it i'm
telling you this [ __ ] right now guys
a drought has your name on it keep a
rotation
and put the masculine [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] friend zone
see i feel like if women knew this is
how men
thought especially like these type of
guys they probably would be a lot less
interested if they realized they were
just one of many
i don't think a lot of girls realize
don't be throwing no [ __ ] that way
that's what i i firmly believe that but
do what you want to do all right
but getting back to the touch barrier
guys don't do that unconfident [ __ ]
all right i told you guys women are not
stupid they know what the [ __ ] you're
doing
it's a check-in you're trying to see
what her [ __ ] interest level is
all right do that sound confident to you
all right
that sounds like a guy that's not that
confident that is a traction
killer all right but getting back to
this how to manipulate i've never really
thought about the texting thing
there is a point where a guy's texting
you too much too early
like the the issue isn't that like he
texts you a lot the issue is if a guy
does it too early and you're wondering
like
you barely know me why are you so like
crazy uh women guys just please
understand that the [ __ ] is dangerous
but if you're gonna do it that's how you
do it you got to get them and they gotta
be submissive to you first
all right gotta give her some institute
ain't no way around that
she can't care about you if she's not
submissive to you
now for you guys that are in a
relationship
or whatever the case may be and you
figure like well how can i get us a
message with a relationship
well a lot of you guys are nothing more
than beta male providers to that woman
all right so if a woman does not care
about a beta male provider
you're nothing but a two sad to say guys
you're nothing but a two
if you're if you're in a relationship
with a woman you're telling me no
beta male has a girl that like cares
about him and you know she's not
submissive to you
and i'll put it to you like guys like
this if you're in a relationship
how do you know if a girl submissive let
me know in the comments
no when a woman is not submissive to you
like she disrespects you
and you're in a relationship or a
marriage or whatever the case may be and
you watching this
she look at you as nothing but a beta
male provider
it is impossible for a woman to care
about
a [ __ ] beta male provider you're
nothing but a two
all right and quite frankly we don't
even care about the alphas they just
care about the way the alpha makes them
feel
all right the alpha makes them feel so
in other words
if he ever gets weak if he ever gets
weak
and he stop making her feel like this
she'll start caring about him too
so in actuality the woman don't even
really care about the alpha she cares
about the way he makes her feel
okay this is it's interesting to see
this because this is definitely the
result of like
feminism i don't need a man type culture
but guys just think about this logically
do you tell me like 50-year marriages
they don't care at all about each other
like that doesn't make sense just like
logically
but it's interesting to see the
repercussions of what i would say
is like feminism and it's really turned
into like i hate men
and then now it's like the men are
coming back saying women are trash
too but let me know what you guys think
in the comments don't forget to
subscribe
i'll talk to you guys next time